biggest break in my career at the time
I'm an ultimate fighter before you go on
to they bring you out and you stay at
The Palace Station Casinos in the
backless strip which are ghetto super
hoodie but the fertitta's owned it so
they put the entire cast there so he
stayed there the night before before you
go into the nice house to get on the
reality show the Only Rule that they
take your phone they go we can't leave
this room he leaves roomie off the show
no matter what happens you leave this
roommate off the show we'll bring you
food you go to sleep wake up we'll take
the house anybody leave this room you're
off the show okay all right fair enough
what's the show uh The Ultimate Fighter
season 10 biggest season all time all
right well so anyway 10 10 million
episodes
it's whatever no dude so I've been told
you don't know this story dino so listen
I'm listening
you've been holding on to that one no
I've said it like seven times yeah yeah
but these guys get it every time okay so
um I fall asleep fall asleep I wake up
to next door shouting I hear two guys
nah [ __ ] nah [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] don't touch me don't [ __ ] me I
hear one guy go and the walls are
papered then I hear one guy go nah [ __ ]
this [ __ ] I'm gonna kill this [ __ ]
hold it down hold it down oh oh what I
wake up like what the [ __ ] is happening
and I hear and he goes nah man no no no
not with a knife get the [ __ ] gun get
the gun and I'm like oh my God these
walls are paper damn I don't want to get
shot and that ladies about to get killed
over there so I'm in my underwear army
crawl it's two in one I'm Army calling
the ground not to get shot and then I
and then I go to unlock the door and he
goes wait wait what's that I'm like
so I'm like trying to do the door all
like quiet and he goes no there's
somebody outside and I just [ __ ] and
I'm like man [ __ ] it I don't get shot I
want to die I'd rather not do this [ __ ]
yeah yeah I'm like if they fire me for
this and [ __ ] it I open that door I
[ __ ] Sprint down the hallway my
Underoos I get to the main like main
area I get the to the casino I'm like
dude uh these two pimps about to kill
this hooker inside the [ __ ] room you
gotta get up there I mean you don't know
that that's what no it was I heard him
yeah yeah they're talking about money
and her sucking dick so then they
[ __ ] get security like right show us
the room like well it's 201 I don't want
to [ __ ] go up there yeah yeah he's
201 like well you just come with us I'm
like I'm Emma can I get a change of
clothes in my underwear like just show
us you go around your room so I'm going
up there and then they're like just stay
here I'm like dude I'm in my [ __ ]
underwear they get them they're fighting
they're fighting and the guy sees me and
he's in cuffs at this point they're
driving the only us oh hell no white boy
all right we see what's up we coming
back here we gonna kill you we're gonna
kill you and I'm like what I'm like no
no I was walking in my room he's like
God [ __ ] you tattletail you [ __ ]
snitch and we're gonna come back and
kill my boys I'm gonna come we're gonna
kill you I'm like oh right so get scared
I'm like can I just change rooms like
we're booked man I was like well no just
then I don't want to stay here they're
like where are you going to go and then
The Ultimate Fighter staff's like no we
don't have another room for you you have
to stay here you have to show come on so
I literally stayed up all night rocking
back and forth Oh I thought you said I
thought you were going to the story was
going to be but I died at the door and
they were and they were playing like
yeah that's video five we thought that
you died this is a real [ __ ] yeah no no
that it was uh what's the Grand Theft
Auto that they were playing like killer
[ __ ] killer [ __ ] it up and I thought
you were gonna look in and they were
playing a video game do you understand
what I'm saying okay now this is Real
Deal First 48 [ __ ] holy [ __ ] yeah so
then what happened and I talked they
were like you just gotta stay here
nothing I was literally so scared all
night and nothing happened they picked
me up the next morning at 7 A.M drove to
the house as my first time in the house
didn't sleep and there was a woman in
the in the place yeah but then when the
cops came to the rest of dude she
started fighting the cop of course oh
yeah she loved her pants and I respect
it that's the scariest thing for cops
domestic violence because they get there
and the wife is all beat up then they
start the day get off my man no you know
what you know what's even serious that's
my husband yep that's my husband titty
all Bruce